♪♪
Lin:
It started with a simple choice,
escape or die.
♪♪
Lin:
In that moment, I didn’t dare
think I might be free.
♪♪
I was introduced to this novel,
Charlie Hunnam:
Shantaram,
and just fell madly in love with
it,
♪♪
Charlie Hunnam:
and I wanted to come back to TV
because of this series.
Lin:
Every day on the run is your
whole life.
Lin:
There’s hope and excitement in
the new.
♪♪
Sujaya Dasgupta:
Shantaram means “Man of God’s
peace,”
and it reflects the man that Lin
wants to be.
Lin’s past life is driving him
on this journey for redemption.
Karla:
You can be free of anything but
yourself.
You don’t know anything about
me.
I thought there was something
worth knowing.
It’s about the discovery of
one’s self
Antonia Desplat:
merged with the vibrant world
that is India.
Karla:
I don’t want to know your
secrets, Lin.
In Bombay everyone’s story is
their own to keep.
He goes on a wonderful journey,
Charlie Hunnam:
finds a lot of friends.
Prabhu:
You are in need of assistance?
I can show you everything.
Okay, you win.
Charlie Hunnam:
If you don’t trust people,
you’re never going to survive
what India demands of you.
Come home, with me.
Prabhu is leading Lin to
salvation.
Prabhu:
Here, everyone’s helping each
other.
♪♪
Lin:
Back home, I drove an ambulance.
I could do more with better
supplies.
Khader Khan:
I’ve heard you are the foreign
doctor.
I wonder what compels you.
There are times when you need to
go to the dark side in order
to reach salvation.
Fate saw fit to throw us
together.
That pure drive to be good,
that is what allows
the underworld bosses to
manipulate Lin.
♪♪
What do you want with him?
Khader Khan:
I just see someone who needs
help to find their path.
So often, in trying to do the
right thing
in this world he doesn’t really
understand,
Steve Lightfoot:
he ends up doing the wrong
thing
Steve Lightfoot:
and now he’s got something else
he has to make up for.
There are no good men or bad
men,
Khader Khan:
it is what they do
that makes them good or evil.
Karla:
For a man who doesn’t want
trouble you keep interesting company.
Does that include you?
Steve Lightfoot:
As big and huge as the story
gets,
Steve Lightfoot:
it’s fundamentally about a man
who’s just trying to be able
to look himself in the mirror and
like what he sees.
♪♪
Lin:
I want to be the man I was gonna
be,
before all of this.
♪♪